Recursion is maybe one of the most
confusing subjects in computer science.
If you get stuck at any point,
keep studying the examples and
try to find some more examples
until it sticks for you.
The idea here is to create
a function that calls itself.
Here is a really basic
example in pseudo code.
This code doesn't do
anything interesting, but
it shows the main parts
of a recursive function.
First of all, a recursive function
needs to call itself at some point.
Second, a recursive
function needs a base case.
You can think of a recursive function
kind of like a while loop in
some regards.
You keep going through some
code again and again and
again until you hit some exit condition.
In a recursive function, the base
case is like the exit condition.
It let's you know when you need to stop.
Without a nice base case like this,
you could get stuck in something
called infinite recursion.
That means your code keeps calling
itself and executing again, and again,
and again, and again, and again.
But because you never tell it when to
stop, it just keeps going infinitely.
The third thing a recursive
function needs to do
is alter the input
parameter at some point.
If you aren't altering
the input parameter or
giving yourself some condition for
changing every time you iterate,
you'll never really know when to stop.
And again, you end up in the same
bad place with infinite recursion.
Okay, now we're going to
go through an example.
This is the code that
we're starting with, and
on this side, I'll write out
each major line that we execute.
So we're going to start by calling
the function with an input value of 2.
We'll start with this if clause.
Since our input value is 2, and
that's greater than 0,
we move on to the else part.
We start by evaluating this before we
assign anything to the variable output.
Okay, so input- 1, that's just 2- 1.
So we're going to call
this function again, but
instead with an input value of 1 and
not 2.
So this is the really confusing part.
Your computer knows that you still
haven't finished that initial call
with the input value of 2.
You're just jumping into
this part without finishing.
In its temporary memory,
it will remember that.
However, it essentially makes a copy
of all of this initial code, and
you have to do it again, but
this time with an input value of 1.
I put an indent here to signal that we
haven't actually finished this initial
call yet, but we're just doing
a call inside of that right now.
Okay, so let's do this again.
This time, the input value is 1,
but that's still greater than 0, so
we can skip down to the else block.
The same thing happens a second time.
Before we assign anything to output,
we have to do this recursive statement.
This time, the input value's 1,
so 1- 1 is 0.
And we have to call this recursive
block again, but with a value of 0,
instead of 1 or 2.
Again, I indented to indicate that we
still haven't forgotten about the fact
that we never solved this and returned
anything, but we do need to move on and
start executing again.
All right, let's do this again.
So this time, we actually have
something interesting here.
The input value is 0, so we never get
to execute any of this else block.
We're just staying up here.
We return 0, so
we see it pop up over here.
Now that we've actually returned
something from one of our calls,
we can forget about this recursive
with an input of 0 and go back to that
recursive with an input of 1 that
we were looking at a minute ago.
All right, so
we return to having an input of 1.
We evaluated this statement to 0,
as I indicated over here.
Again, remember, we called
the recursive block, we return 0.
So now we say that this whole
thing evaluates to 0, and
we can assign 0 to output, great.
Now that call we did where
the input was 1 actually
has a return value here, which is 0.
So now we can kind of forget
about this recursive block and
move back to that original call,
where our input was 2.
Okay, so back to the original call,
this call,
which used to be recursive with
an input of 1, got evaluated to 0.
So now we can say 0 is equal to output.
And again, we can return 0, and
now even our initial call is done.
Great, so the initial call returns 0.
Recursion can be really confusing,
because you start out with just this one
method, but you don't even know how
many times you'll end up calling it.
When I'm trying to think through
how a recursive function works,
I'll often write out a table or
a list of steps like this, so
I can keep track of my values every
time I hit the recursive block again.
I always used to think of it like my
computer was just going on tangents.
I started with this initial function,
and then I kept calling something else,
and doing something else, and
doing something else, and
doing something else.
And eventually, I would get back to the
thing I was talking about originally.
Remember, your code is going to go
through these lines of code in order.
It's never going to assign
this output any number
until you've hit the recursive
block as many times as you need.
Remember to be really careful when
you're writing recursive code.
If your base case doesn't make sense,
you could end up doing
infinite recursion.
Let's say we change this
base case just a little bit.
All I did was get rid of
the less than or equal to and
replaced it with just equal to.
Now this code is going to run fine
if we give it an input value of 2 or
1 or 4 or even 1 million.
But if the input value
was actually less than 0,
this code's never going to return.
If you start out with -2,
you'll skip the if block, and
you'll just keep subtracting 1.
Next time, your input's going to be -3.
Then you'll subtract 1, -4.
Subtract 1, -5, and so forth.
If I use less than though,
if my number initially is -2 or
-50 or -1 million, I'll stop as
soon as I hit the base case.
Remember to think about all the
different input values your recursive
statement could have.
Lastly, if you're really not sure
what your recursive block is doing,
you can use print statements
wherever necessary.
By printing out intermediate values,
you'll get a sense of exactly what your
code is doing at exactly which steps.